ДО, РЕ, МІ.
ДОбрий, РЕгулярний секс з МІнімальним ризиком.
Або з презервативом, як по нотах.
Це слоган цьогорічної всеукраїнської кампанії
«Не дай СНІДу шансу!»
За безпечний секс у міжнародний день боротьби
з ВІЛ/СНІДом агітують український рок-гурт
«Друга ріка» та німецький «Ван Гольцен».
Спільний концерт у Києві відбувається в рамках
всеукраїнської кампанії «Не дай СНІДу шансу!».
Фронтмена «Другої ріки» Валерія Харчишина шокує,
що Україна серед лідерів за темпами поширення ВІЛ
і що 73% нових випадків інфікування
відбувається статевим шляхом.
Коли там градус кохання зашкалює , ти ні про що
не думаєш, ти вже роздягаєшся і біжиш, не думаючи,
я би сказав: чуваки, хлопці, мужики!
Втрачайте голову від кохання, але
не втрачайте розум! Убезпечтесвоє кохання
презервативом, і тоді буде вам щастя!
А колеги Харчишина з Німеччини -
18-ти-річні рок-музиканти з гурту «Ван Гольцен»
переконані, що надзвичайно важливо, аби про
ВІЛ/СНІД і безпечний секс українським підліткам
розповідали в рамках шкільної програми, як у ФРН.
Це дуже важливо. Чим раніше це робитимуть,
тим краще. Треба ще в дитинстві про це
розповідати, щоб підлітки  замислювалися над
цими темамиі були обізнаними.
Кампанія «Не дай СНІДу шансу!» стартувала
в Україні в 2009 році за ініціативою німецького уряду.
Головна мета -профілактика розповсюдження ВІЛ/СНІД.
Для цього проводяться безкоштовні тестування
на вірус імунодефіциту, тренінги для
лікарів, учителів, молоді.
Участь у заходах, організованих Німецьким
товариством міжнародного співробітництва, взяли
вже загалом понад 200000 українців.
Сьогодні вже неможливо собі уявити, що ще
у 80-х роках у Німеччині темуВІЛ/СНІД взагалі
не піднімали, про це не говорили, деяких людей,
як-от гомосексуалів, не приймали в суспільстві,
вважалося, що заразитися можуть лише певні
маргінальні групи, розповсюджувалися божевільні
міфи про те, звідки взялася ця хвороба.
Нині все це вже в минулому.
І ми помічаємо, що це змінюється також в Україні.
Люди стають значно обізнаніші.
На великому рок-концерті у Києві
музиканти співають безкоштовно.
Квитки на концерт теж безкоштовні.
Їхотримали усі, хто пройшов тест про користь
презервативів на сайті продажу квитків.
Про це зі сцени говоритимуть також
українські і німецькі музиканти.
Кажуть: хочуть поширити серед слухачів не лише
свою музику, а і нову моду - на презервативи.